I'm happy to announce my new course on Applied Cryptography!
Cryptography means secret writing-- it goes back to the earliest human desires to keep and share secrets
In the early days, cryptography was only available to generals and emperors
but today, it is used by nearly everyone, everyday.
Every time you do a credit card transaction,
make a phone call, use a secure website, you're using cryptography.
In this class we'll start by learning the mathematical foundations behind cryptography.
Then we'll see how to use cryptography to solve problems in computing.
We'll see how to use cryptography to manage passwords, and user accounts.
To do secure transactions, to make money from nothing but numbers
and to do computation while keeping your data private.
Cryptography is a really fun topic! It's all about making, and breaking puzzles.
I hope we'll see you in class.